[Musique]
selon une étude menée par l'institut de
technologie du massachusetts
en 1970 la quantité d'énergie artificiel
fabriqué par une grande ville
industrielle était égal à l'énergie
reçue du soleil par cette ville pour
l'ensemble de la terre la quantité
d'énergie produite par l'homme serait
seulement 1000 fois plus petite que
celle reçue du soleil mais elles
augmentent de 3% par an enfin il est
probable que la mise en valeur des
terres incultes le défrichement
l'urbanisation ont aussi eu une
incidence sur le climat ne serait ce que
parce qu'ils modifient le pouvoir
réfléchissant de grandes étendues de
terrain il est donc possible qu'une
augmentation de la température moyenne
de l'atmosphère soit à craindre
s'il y avait un réchauffement ce
réchauffement actuel
enfin le réchauffement que l'on pourrait
envisager sera un réchauffement très
faible ce serait soit réchauffement
d'origine naturelle ce serait aussi de
l'ordre de quelques dixièmes de degrés
soit un réchauffement artificielle
provoquée par les activités humaines
ce serait du même ordre de grandeur
mettons que l'on aille jusqu'à 1 degré
les conséquences seraient à peine
perceptible mais supposons qu'un
réchauffement de 3 à 5 degrés se
produisent que se passerait-il alors et
c'est difficile à prévoir
objectivement fin supposons qu un tel
réchauffement se produise il y aurait
fusion d'une partie de la calotte
glaciaire peut-être même disparition
totale des glaces au pôle nord car on
changerait que le bilan énergétique du
fait de la disparition temporaire des
glaces il aurait une augmentation du
niveau des océans en particulier de pont
bien je ne peux pas faire le calcul de
tête comme ça mais il est probable que
les terres basses les rivages des océans
serait
recouvert par les eaux
nuance de l'activité humaine sur le
climat réchauffement ou refroidissement
de la terre bien des hypothèses
contradictoires ont été avancés et
l'opinion publique s'interroge
moi je crois une chose que depuis il ya
tout ce qui vous l'ont lherm accueillons
un peu d'être à pierre a pu le temps je
ne sais pas s'il n'y a pas quelque chose
de là haut qui nous a un petit peu
chamboulée depuis je crois qu'on a fait
des expériences dans le cosmo là je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose de déranger
ou bien alors il ya un cycle long que
nous n'avons pas connu l'avant cycle de
maintenant tout le monde vous dira que
c'est un peu la bombe à taghit l'enfant
moi j'aimerais parfois c'est un peu
peut-être façon générale la taille qui
se réchauffe qui sont refroidis
[Musique]